[Music]
not that long ago
a user called diego left a comment on
one of my videos
now seems like an appropriate occasion
to share what he wrote
congrats on 200 subscribers glad to see
this channel grow
remember me when you reach 100k
no doubt you've seen this title so allow
me to cut to the chase
thank you so much for 100 000
subscribers
this number astounds me it's an amount
of people that i really struggle to
visualize in my head
but to think that one hundred thousand
individual people liked my content
enough to subscribe
it's just amazing beyond belief i
started this channel in may 2020
so i haven't really been around for very
long it came at a time when
due to a particularly pressing world
event people were indoors
with not a lot to do so i decided to
give myself a project
to start a channel i had but one simple
aim
to learn how to edit videos and use
video editing software
at the time i did not expect anyone to
watch what i made
only me just a singular subscriber it
didn't matter though
my video editing was improving i decided
to make videos on anything i found
interesting
covering obscure topics that deserve
more attention it was an eclectic mix
london gentleman's clubs fonts live
television interruptions
and so on and then i made a video on
bible accurate angels
i remember waking up the next day after
uploaded it seeing that 93 people had
watched the video overnight
and the very first subscribers were
trickling in i did not anticipate what
would happen next
in the meantime i continued to make
videos i covered the hearing hymn
origins of the grim reaper biblical
mythical beasts and so on
this time however they were actually
getting views
no doubt excited my aim was still the
same to improve my video editing skills
with each and every upload
then the all-knowing youtube algorithm
picked up my angels video
and sent it all across the platform it's
likely the video that brought you here
and it's my largest video to date
well this leaves me here 100k
again thank you so much for being part
of this journey with me
and looking at some of the heartfelt
comments that have been left in my
videos really means the world and
continues to inspire me as i produce
content
i'm awesome on thank yous a brief shout
out to a smaller channel
toasters who's been running the discord
server head on down there if you haven't
already
i've even met some of you on there and
it's been really great to see you
i've also just set up a channel
instagram and twitter so follow me there
for more content
a final thanks is to bim a really good
friend of mine and a channels og
subscriber
you'll know who you are i'll end my
video with this
if you're wanting to make a channel
produce music write a book
or do anything else creative you
absolutely can
the key thing is just to start it
doesn't matter whether it's good or not
what matters is that you've started the
trick to help me to make these videos
is the 70 percent rule just do things at
70 of your capability
and allow you to move forward and not
get bogged down by the finer details
perfectionism really stifles creativity
anyway if you want to start something
new just go for it
anyone can be creative just begin and
see where it takes you
oh and if you're wondering season 2 is
dropping later this month
get ready i think you'll enjoy what's on
the way
we've only just begun